Dass Goethe eine Rolle bei der
Entwicklung der Evolutionswissenschaft spielte, ist
umstritten. In seinen Schriften zur
Biologie und Zoologie wollte Goethe
die etablierte Praxis der
Naturkunde, die seiner
Ansicht nach auf Klassengrenzen nach
manifesten Merkmalen oder isolierten
Merkmalen beruhte, durch die ersetzen  Suche nach einem
Typ oder Bauplan, der hinter
der Entwicklung aller Lebewesen in
der Mitte des 19. Jahrhunderts steht William Huell behauptet,
dass Goethes Wechsel von diesen
Merkmalen zum morphologischen
Typ von den besten Autoritäten anerkannt wurde
Zitat während der frühen Bildung des
biologischen Denkens Charles Darwin scheint
um Fuels Beobachtung ein paar Jahre später zu verleihen,
indem er Goethe als extremen
Anhänger seiner Transmutations- oder Artensicht bezeichnete, kurz nachdem Hermann von Helmholtz
behauptete, es sei Goethes Morphologie gewesen
, die es ermöglicht habe, dass Darwins
Biologie so schnell in
Deutschland aufgenommen wurde  19. Jahrhundert aber
Historiker der Biologie ha  Während wir dazu neigten, ein
solches Lob von Goethes
Morphologie als fehlgeleitet abzulehnen, im Gegensatz zu
der genetischen Drift, die die
Dynamik der darwinistischen Physiologie untermauert,
legen sie nahe, dass Goethes Suche nach
einem grundlegenden Typ
mit der Beschäftigung des 18
stellt
Goethe als einen Essentialisten dar und George
Wells behauptet, dass Goethe
die Möglichkeit einer groß angelegten
Evolution nicht akzeptieren konnte, also möchte ich in diesem Artikel
etwas Druck auf diese Behauptungen
ausüben, indem ich mich auf ein übersehenes Konzept in seinen Schriften zur Morphologie konzentriere, das auch
von mir übersehen wurde  Bis heute wurde
das Konzept der Ökonomie der Natur
in den späten 1780er Jahren
zunehmend davon überzeugt, dass sich die
Wissenschaft mit den Kräften befasst, die
die Teile und Prozesse organischer
Körper bewegen, einschließlich der Physiologie, Anatomie und
Chemie, und ließ die Beziehung zwischen
organischen Teilen Anfang der
1790er Jahre ungeklärt  er begann
mit einer neuen Analogie zu erweitern, wonach die Natur X
ist  als eine Reihe von ineinander verschlungenen
Haushaltsbudgets untersucht, die von einem
Verteilungsprinzip bestimmt werden, das er den
formativen Trieb auf der Ebene des
singulären Organismus nannte, ermöglicht die Analogie
dem Naturforscher, die Beziehung
zwischen den Teilen als Mitgliedern eines
Wirtschaftssystems zu untersuchen, ohne
über verborgene Mechanismen spekulieren zu müssen
die hinter den
so konzipierten Erscheinungen wirken, wird die Beziehung zwischen den
Teilen nicht durch eine äußere
Kraft oder ein vorher festgelegtes Ziel bestimmt, sondern der
Gestaltungstrieb verteilt
verfügbare Ressourcen frei nach einem Plan,
der wie eine Künstlerin vor ihrer Staffelei
eine potenziell unendliche Vielfalt hervorbringen könnte
formt, aber die ökonomische
Analogie eröffnet auch eine höhere Ebene, von
der aus der Naturforscher die Natur
als ein verflochtenes Netzwerk von Austauschvorgängen betrachten kann,
das zu einer Vielzahl von Strukturplänen
führt, die durch das
Zusammenwirken des festen Gestaltungstriebs
mit äußeren Bedingungen so bestimmt werden, wie sie identifiziert werden können
Goethes ökonomische Analogie ermöglicht
Was ich für eine umfassende Betrachtung
morphologischer Studien halte Ich werde einen
kontextualisierten Ansatz wählen, um festzustellen, was
ich für eine Verschiebung in Goethes
Denken hin zu dieser Ansicht halte, daher beginne ich damit,
Goethes Suche nach einer
typologischen Norm insbesondere in den späten 1780er Jahren zu betrachten
In seiner italienischen Reise,
die 1790 in seinem Aufsatz zur Erklärung der
Metamorphose der Pflanzen gipfelte, erkenne ich dann
eine Verschiebung, die mit seinem Aufsatz beginnt,
dem ersten Entwurf einer allgemeinen
Einführung in die vergleichende Anatomie, in
der Goethe den formenden
Drang einführt, seine früheren Arbeiten zur
Typologie mit zu integrieren  morphologische
Überlegungen und im letzten Abschnitt
werde ich Curtis Darstellung der
Entwicklung der Morphologie in einem sehr
merkwürdigen Aufsatz mit dem Titel Formativer Trieb oder
Aufbau des Schlafs im Jahr 1810 betrachten, um darüber nachzudenken, wie
Goethe den Platz seiner
Theorie in der Entwicklung der
Lebenswissenschaften auffasste
Während er also keine Mechanik
der Transmutation anbietet, behaupte ich, dass Goethes
ökonomische Analogie einen Kobold kennzeichnet  Ein bedeutender
Fortschritt in der Erforschung der organischen Form,
denn er verortet die komparative Natalie
innerhalb eines biodynamischen Austauschsystems,
in dem die Gesetzmäßigkeit des
morphologischen Typs durch
die Freiheit des Gestaltungstriebs zum Ausdruck
kommt
Darwin von
Goethe von Darwin und Helmholtz,
so werde ich in der Zeitung vorgehen, aber ich war
ein bisschen unaufrichtig, weil ich
Abschnitt zwei überspringen werde, weil
ich dies als kapitellanges Stück geschrieben habe
und es ein bisschen zu lang ist  Ich werde
Ihnen eine sehr kurze Zusammenfassung geben, also beginne
ich dort mit einem Blick auf die italienischen Ich-
Eliza-Texte, in denen Goethe beginnt,
von seiner frühen Beschäftigung mit
Linnaeus und der Klassifizierung zu einer Suche
nach dem überzugehen, was er begann, die
Urpflanze Erde Lanza und das zu nennen  ist eine
Verschiebung, da Dark Outputs
in einem ihrer Artikel sehr ergreifend sind, von der
Betrachtung von Produkten hin zur Betrachtung der
Produktivität selbst, und die Erde Lunz
ist eine Möglichkeit, den Profi einzufangen  Entwicklung der
Pflanzen durch die verschiedenen Stadien, die
sich auf diese Idee eines sich reproduzierenden Organs konzentrieren,
das
Goethe in diesen Schriften als das Blatt
identifizierte  seine Reflexion über die
Ontologie dieses Entstehungsprozesses im Text
in den 1790er Jahren, an der ich sehr interessiert bin,
also werde ich zu
Abschnitt 3 springen, aber ich könnte später mehr darüber sagen.
Ich denke, ein Großteil der Wissenschaft
konzentriert sich auf Dachrinnen  Arbeiten über die Metamorphose
von Pflanzen, und daher denke ich, dass uns einiges davon
bereits bekannt ist. Wenn ich jetzt
an die Entwicklung seiner vergleichenden
Anatomie denke, folgt die Erklärung, die Goethe
in seinem Aufsatz zur Erklärung der
morphischen Metamorphose von Pflanzen im Jahr 1790 vorlegt,
nicht dem Modell von Newton
von halle skizzierte physiologie, die
morphologische änderungen
gemäß lebenden kräften berücksichtigt, die dazu führen, dass sich eine
vorgeformte miniatur
zu a ausdehnt  voll entwickelte Form
noch folgt das Modell
dem Modell des Possenreißers mechanischer
Vitalismus, bei dem die Form eines lebenden
Körpers das Ergebnis organischer Materie ist, die
durch eine durchdringende Kraft in eine innere Form gepresst
wird
Goethes gefundener fundamentaler
Baustein ein pflanzliches Leben das Blatt
ist keine vorstrukturierte Form, die
hinter dem morphologischen Prozess arbeitet,
sondern ein Prinzip der Veränderung, das sich in
der Vielfalt der Formen manifestiert, die von den
verschiedenen Teilen der Pflanze angenommen werden. Das SI ist
insofern eine Erklärung, als
es den Prozess beschreibt, durch den das Blatt
entsteht  zum Ausdruck in den verschiedenen
Teilen der Pflanze durch einen zeitlichen Prozess
der Expansion und Kontraktion,
der es dem Leser ermöglicht, diesen Prozess
in jeder Pflanze zu sehen, so erklärt es, indem
es den Leser für den Prozess
hinter der Pflanzenentwicklung nach der
Veröffentlichung von si zur Erklärung der
Metamorphose animiert  von Pflanzen im Jahr 1790
kehren für eine zweite Reise nach Italien zurück,
die eine Erfahrung lieferte, die h  Wir werden
uns später als einen Schlüsselmoment
in seinem sich entwickelnden Gedanken erinnern, als Goethe bei
seinem regelmäßigen Spaziergang entlang des Lido in
Venedig auf
einen Schafsschädel stieß, dessen Schädel so offen war,
dass seine Erinnerung an seine früheren
Arbeiten über das Intermaxillarium überflutet wurde  Knochen, wo
er behauptet hatte, dass sich der Schädel
aus den Wirbeln entwickelt, doch die Erfahrung
eröffnete eine neue Analogie, die es Ger ermöglichte
, die sequentielle
Entfaltung der Wirbel mit der
Entwicklung des Blattes
quer zur Pflanzenachse zu verbinden, und dies zitiert
Goethe  vor seinen Augen den Übergang
von inneren ungeformten organischen Massen
durch ihre Entwicklung nach außen über
die fortschreitende Verfeinerung der
höchsten Formation und Evolution zu den
hervorragendsten sensorischen Werkzeugen in Anführungszeichen wie
die Pflanze aus transformierten Blättern besteht,
so der Schädel aus
verwandelten Wirbeln besteht, die
sichtbare Spuren hinterlassen  einer Homologie zwischen der
Knochenstruktur bei
Tieren und Menschen durch Identifizierung
als  Strukturplan oder Darmplan, den ich
, der Wirbeltiere innerhalb einer einzigen Gruppe vereint,
entdeckte Goethe einen Weg,
sein morphologisches Denken über Pflanzen
auf das Tierreich auszudehnen. Seine neue Erkenntnis
fiel zusammen mit einer wachsenden Sorge um die
Grundlagen wissenschaftlicher Erkenntnisse und
die geeigneten Untersuchungsmethoden
Durch eine, wie er es nannte, glückliche
Begegnung mit dem jungen Friedrich
Schiller
, der Goethe dazu drängte, seine Suche
nach einem physiologischen Typus im
Rahmen der Karren transzendentalen
Erkenntnistheorie zu betrachten, war Goethe bereits
mit der Karren transzendentalen
Darstellung der Natur in der Kritik der reinen
Vernunft vertraut und hatte ein gewisses Interesse gefunden  In
Kants Ablehnung äußerer Ursachen
zwar metaphysischer Grundlagen, aber
die erkenntnistheoretischen Beschränkungen, die Kant den
Ideen
auferlegte, konnten Goethes Spinoza sztyc Intuitionen nicht durchdringen, als
er Karren dritte Kritik las, jedoch
die Notwendigkeit erkennen, dass er nur
methodologische Fragen in Betracht ziehen muss
zweite pa  rt der dritten Kritik Kant
bestreitet, dass organische Form
durch äußere Ursachen erklärt werden kann, schlägt er vor,
dass natürliche Variation nur
als dynamische Wechselwirkung
zwischen äußeren Kräften betrachtet werden kann, die auf
Lebewesen einwirken und sich in einer zweckgebundenen Nosov-
Interpretation in Goethes Wechselwirkungsinterpretation selbst gestalten  zumindest vielleicht
nicht genau, aber wie er die Nachteile las,
demonstrierte Kant, dass organische Produktivität
mit künstlerischer Produktivität verwandt ist. Beide
existieren um ihrer selbst willen.
Um bei Kant zu entdecken,
dass wir zwar
berücksichtigen müssen, dass Naturprodukte
von der Umwelt geprägt sind, die ewige innere
Struktur von Lebewesen nicht
durch eine äußere Ursache erklärt werden kann, führt dies
dazu, dass morphologische Konzepte
wie der
Kräuterflanger keine Beobachtungsobjekte sind  sondern
eher Ideen, die die Untersuchung irgendwie leiten,
als Ideen, die sie nicht können b  e mit dem
physischen Auge gesehen werden, erfordern jedoch die
Betrachtung des inneren Auges, so dass die Jahre, die
auf diese Begegnung mit dem Schafsschädel folgten
, intensiv daran arbeiten
, eine neue Wissenschaft der Morphologie zu skizzieren.
Sechs Monate nach seiner zweiten
Reise nach
Italien begann er seinen ersten Versuch Essay  Über die
Form der Tiere In diesem Aufsatz
kündigte Goethe seine Absicht an, die
allgemeine Form zu definieren, die das Tierreich eint.
Seine Methode besteht darin, das Skelettwachstum bei Säugetieren zu untersuchen, um
nach dem zu suchen
, was er einen osteologischen Typus nennt,
der zu den mannigfaltigen Formen führt
Begegnungen im Laufe der Erfahrung eine
solche Methode, die Goethe betont, sei rein
empirisch, sie erkläre nicht, wie die
Knochen auf diese Weise zusammenkommen,
sondern beschreibe den allen Wirbeltieren gemeinsamen Prozess, der
die Ursache für die
Ähnlichkeit der unterschiedlichsten Formen sei, die er
behauptet  unveränderliche Verbindung
der Teile untereinander In den nächsten
fünf Jahren verfasste Goethe vier weitere
Abhandlungen über die allgemeine Gestalt  einer
Säugetieraxt in einem Aufsatz über eine allgemeine Theorie der
Knochen schlägt er eine empirische
Untersuchung des Wirbeltierskeletts vor und
bietet eine detaillierte Beschreibung des
Kopfes bis zum Rückgrat, während
er den vorläufigen Charakter seiner Studien anerkennt,
die sich nur auf ein Element
im Skelett konzentrieren  Entwicklungsprozess der
Wirbel Goethe wollte einen
experimentellen Weg zu einer
Metamorphose der Tiere erarbeiten, die nie
wirklich bevorstand,
aber immer eine Hoffnung am Horizont schwebte. Ein solcher
Standard konnte nicht von einem
einzelnen Exemplar oder einer Art abgeleitet werden, sondern als
Schema, nach dem die  Skelette
bestimmter existierender Arten konnten
verglichen und ihre Variationen beschrieben werden,
als er ein neues Programm für
vergleichende Anatomie entwickelte.
Goethe schrieb auch einen methodologischen Text
mit dem Titel Essay über eine allgemeine Theorie des
Vergleichs, den ich für einen sehr
wichtigen Text in seiner Entwicklung halte, den
wir hier erkennen können  Ein wachsender Einfluss
Schillers und schneidet die Kritik an
Goethes Denken aber mit Goet ab  Seine eigene
nuancierte Art, sie zu verstehen,
beginnt damit, dass er die geringen Fortschritte beklagt, die
in der Physiologie im Vergleich zu den
anderen Wissenschaften gemacht wurden, die seiner Meinung nach auf
die traditionelle Vorstellung von
Lebewesen als Produkte eines externen
Zwecks zurückzuführen sind, wenn physiologische Bewegung
in einem Newton untersucht wird  Der
Naturforscher ist zwar in der Lage, nach Gesetzen zu suchen,
die bestimmte Arten organischer Materie regeln, er
kann jedoch die
Wechselwirkung zwischen tatsächlichen Teilen eines
organischen Körpers nicht erklären, um die Form eines
organischen Körpers auf der Suche nach Gesetzen zu untersuchen,
muss der Newtonsche Physiologe das
Produkt von a annehmen  Wenn
man jedoch die Priorität ablehnt, die
Newtons Darstellung der Kraft in der Physiologie eingeräumt wird,
könnte man den formenden Prozess
als Ergebnis eines inneren Prinzips untersuchen,
das einem einzigen Muster folgt, so dass
die primäre Vergleichsfrage ist,
wie ein umgebendes Element wie Wasser
oder  Luft beeinflusst den Ausdruck einer
allgemeinen Form
Goethes Ziel ist es, die zu verschieben
Leserperspektive von einem Zustand des Staunens über
die Komplexität des Designs bis hin zur Suche nach
der Funktionalität von Teilen im
Kontext einer ganzen Umgebung Das innere
Prinzip bestimmt das allgemeine
Muster als Reaktion auf äußere Kräfte. Entschuldigung, ich habe
gerade meinen Platz
bei der Untersuchung des verloren  Der organische Körper
als ein sich selbst produzierendes Ganzes eröffnet das, was er
eine höhere Beobachtungsebene nennt, von
der aus man die
organisierte Welt selbst als eine
Wechselbeziehung vieler Elemente betrachten kann. Ende
Zitat
Wenn die Welt als ein sich selbst
produzierendes Ganzes betrachtet wird, kann man die
Pflanze sehen  Reich ist für
Insekten lebensnotwendig Ozeane und Flüsse
sind für Fische notwendig, so dass
man die ganze Welt der Tiere als ein
großes Element sehen kann, in dem eine Art
durch und durch die andere geschaffen oder zumindest erhalten wird, ohne dass
Goethe darauf
eingeht  Diese bemerkenswerte Beobachtung
in seinem methodologischen Aufsatz hier
kommt er zu dem Schluss, dass die
Konzeption der natürlichen Ordnung als Dynam  ic sich
selbst hervorbringende Ganze zerstört jeden
Hinweis auf die Verbindungen und
Beziehungen in der Natur in Bezug auf
Zweck oder Absicht, so dass Goethes Aufsatz
über eine allgemeine Vergleichstheorie meines
Erachtens ein Übergangstext ist
, der zwischen seinen früheren Arbeiten über den
osteologischen Typus in den Aufsätzen Wir steht.  Ich habe mir
gerade einen neuen Text angesehen, den
er 1795 fertiggestellt hat und auf den ich mich jetzt konzentrieren möchte. Er
nannte den ersten Entwurf einer
allgemeinen Einführung in die vergleichende
Anatomie auf der Grundlage der Osteologie. Seine frühere
Arbeit über den Zwischenkieferknochen suchte Goethe
nach einem allgemeinen Design, indem
er die Struktur beobachtete  Merkmale, die
alle Wirbeltiere durch seine Studie
über morphologische Veränderungen gemeinsam haben, Goethe räumt jedoch ein
, dass dieser Ansatz
die verschiedenen Formen, die
Wirbeltiere annehmen können, nicht berücksichtigt. Die Aufgabe besteht darin, nicht
einfach anzuerkennen, dass organische
Strukturen an eine bestimmte Umgebung angepasst sind,
sondern zu verstehen, wie organische
Strukturen  existiert in und durch seine
Umwelt, wie er in der ersten
Gliederung erklärt  Anstatt zu behaupten, dass einem
Stier Hörner gegeben wurden, damit er es kann, sondern
wir stattdessen versuchen sollten, herauszufinden, wie er
Hörner entwickelt haben könnte, die er verwendet, um den Rock zu stoßen, ist eine
Skizze eine neue Vergleichsmethode
, die die anatomische Form als
Ergebnis einer betrachtet  Prozess, durch den die
Struktur von Lebewesen sowohl
von außen als auch von mit
ihm geprägt wird. Ziel ist es, die Analyse
vom Vergleich von Sorten gegen einen
Standard wie den Menschen auf das
gesamte Tierreich auszudehnen, um ein gemeinsames
Muster abzuleiten oder  typ also kann keine
art als vorbild stehen dies bedeutet aber nicht,
dass der typ eine transzendente
idee ist die irgendwie über der vielfalt schwebt
es geht um zustände die
physiologisch festgestellt werden müssen ein mittel
um die strukturen aller
tiere zu untersuchen ohne sich darauf beziehen zu müssen  zurück auf
die zuvor
gut untersuchte Tierstruktur, da die Sprache in der ersten
Gliederung erkenntnistheoretisch
selbstreflexiver ist als seine früheren Texte
h  Er stellt fest, dass sein Verfahren zur
vergleichenden Anatomie mit der
Erfahrung einer Farm beginnt, die uns zuerst lehren muss
, welche Teile allen Tieren gemeinsam sind
und wie sich diese Teile von diesem
allgemeinen Vergleich unterscheiden. Wir können dann nach
einer Idee suchen, die das Ganze beherrscht, die
das Allgemeine abstrahiert  Bild in
genetischer Weise er sagt, in diesem empirischen
Verfahren ist der Typus eine Hypothese, die
wir durch Anwendung der üblichen Vergleichsmethoden recht gut testen können
er
sagt, sobald der Typus festgestellt ist,
kann die vergleichende Anatomie
auf der ersten Ebene über zwei Analyseebenen vorgehen
der Typus ermöglicht es dem
Naturforscher, den
Entstehungsprozess als durch einen bestimmten
Strukturplan begrenzt zu betrachten er hat Beschränkungen auf
der zweiten Ebene der Typus ermöglicht es dem
Naturforscher, die enorme
Vielfalt der Tiere als eine abgestufte Reihe von
organisierten Formen zu betrachten, die diese beiden Ebenen
zusammenhalten I  suggerieren ist der Schlüssel zu
Goethes vergleichender Anatomie, denn ihre
Kombination offenbart, dass zwar Quoti  ng
Goethe hier ist
die strukturelle Bandbreite der Natur
begrenzt, da die Anzahl der Teile
und ihre häufigen Modifikationen
die Formänderungen unbegrenzt machen
Die Literatur stellt die beiden
Elemente der vergleichenden Anatomie zusammen mit
der Aufgabe, nach den Gesetzmäßigkeiten zu suchen,
die das Verhältnis zwischen dem Typus und der Umwelt regeln. Der
Typus Goethe
muss unter dem Gesichtspunkt betrachtet werden,
wie verschiedene
Naturkräfte auf ihn einwirken und wie es ihm ebenso geht
Abhängig von den allgemeinen Gesetzen der
Außenwelt kann man beispielsweise feststellen,
dass der Hals und die Extremitäten
bei der Giraffe bevorzugt werden, die
die Reichweite der äußeren Gliedmaßen betont hat,
im Gegensatz zum Maulwurf, der das
umgekehrte Verhältnis aufweist, die Extremitäten werden
heruntergespielt, um seine Intensität zu
priorisieren  Beziehung zum Boden solche
Beobachtungen, die Goethe angibt  s führen zu
einem einzigen Gesetz, das besagt, dass
einem Teil nichts hinzugefügt werden kann, ohne etwas
von einem anderen zu subtrahieren und umgekehrt
carl friedrich heel meyer
ich weise auf den formativen trieb hin, wie
wir bereits gehört haben,
schlug blumenbach eine hierarchie von fünf lebenskräften vor, die
für die verschiedenen organischen
funktionen verantwortlich sind,
beginnend mit halehs reizbarkeit und sensibilität
bis hin zur empfängnis,
ernährung und reproduktion, doch
blumenbach hat das erkannt  Die fünf
Kräfte allein können
die Form organisierter Wesen nicht erklären, er
argumentierte, dass sie
unter einer höheren Kraft organisiert sein müssen, die
quasi sanfte Eigenschaften aufweist, und er
nannte diese Kraft den rechnenden Strom, den
formenden Trieb im Gegensatz zu den fünf
Lebenskräften, die  Vorgegebene
Kapazitäten betreffen die prägende
Antriebskoordinate  die kapazitäten auflädt und durch die änderung
des verhältnisses zwischen ihnen
auf die bedürfnisse des organismus einwirkt dieser
trieb ist nach boom blumenbach
keine lebenskraft, sondern lediglich ein
platzhalter für eine unbekannte ursache und
aufbauend auf halehs analogischer erweiterung
der newtonschen schwerkraft stellt
er fest, dass und wir  dieses Zitat habe ich
schon gehört die formende Kraft soll
nicht weniger dienen als Cygnet ein
Siegel eine Kraft bedeuten ein Handwerk dessen
ständige Wirkung aus
Erfahrung bekannt ist und dessen Ursache wie die
Ursachen der oben genannten weithin
anerkannten Naturkräfte für uns
gleich eine Kultur ist  Sein berühmter
Vortrag, der 1793 in der Hoenn-Kultur gehalten wurde und
sich auf die Beziehung der
organischen Kräfte berief, schlug er vor, eine neue
Methode für die Physiologie zu entwickeln, die die
Verteilung der Form im
Tierreich im Hinblick auf die Beziehung zwischen
den fünf Kräften für seine fünf untersucht  Kräfte sind
etwas anders als Bloomin bellt und
wieder - wie funktioniert Hume Ich war mir bewusst, dass
Kant von Kant interpretieren  ration von
Blumenbach in der dritten Kritik, die
bestritt, dass das Newtonsche
Kraftmodell als Analogie für den
Gestaltungstrieb in unserer eigenen
Zweckmäßigkeit dienen kann, dass Agenten als
Analogie dienen, die zur Folge hat, dass der Gestaltungstrieb
keine Erklärung ist,
spielt keine Erklärung  Rolle in der
Naturwissenschaft, aber im Gegensatz zu Can't Kill
Maya lehnt er den formativen Antrieb
insgesamt ab, stattdessen entfernt er
Blooms Bericht über die Feuerkräfte aus dem,
was wir einen Newtonschen Rahmen nennen könnten, als
unaufrichtig oder genial, was
für Blumenbach sein könnte, und schlägt ein überarbeitetes
Programm vor  in dem die lebende welt
als biodynamisches system von
wechselwirkungen untersucht wird, unterliegt die organisation der fliegenkräfte
dem, was kiermaier das gesetz der kompensation nennt, nach dem
die lebenskräfte in
bezug auf die bedürfnisse eines organismus unter
bestimmten umweltbedingungen proportional sind,
das ist nicht das gesetz  geerdet in einer kraft für
kiermaier for nothing dirigiert das
wechselspiel des for
Es ist fast eine emergente Eigenschaft, aber
Chioma sagt uns leider nicht, in
welchem Sinne das Gesetz der Entschädigung überhaupt ein Gesetz ist,
und es ist in seinem Vortrag ziemlich unklar, dass Goethe zu G
ethe zurückkehrt, sein System dyna
ischer Beziehungen hat klare Reson
nzen mit Kiel Myers  Stud
e über die Beziehung zwischen den
Lebenskräften Außerdem ist sein Tauschgesetz
praktisch eine direkte Paraphrase von Kiel
Myers Ausgleichsgesetz, aber im
Gegensatz dazu bleibt Akhil Meyer die
Blüte von Arcs prägendem Antrieb
als die Kraft, die
hier meiner Meinung nach verschiedene andere Funktionen koordiniert  siehe die
Singularität von Goethes Programm anstelle
von Blüte begibt sich Newtonsche Analogie und
im Gegensatz zu Kiel Myers Ablehnung
jeder koordinierenden Kraft schlägt Goethe
eine ökonomische Analogie vor, in der der
formende Antrieb als Verteilungsprinzip verstanden wird, das als
Reaktion
auf die äußeren Bedingungen von Kräften ausgeht
eine Umgebung betont bestimmte
Strukturmerkmale auf Kosten
anderer und hier ich  Haben Sie ein erweitertes Zitat
aus der ersten Gliederung dort, was
in der Handreichung steht und das deutsche Original
ist auf der Rückseite, wenn Sie möchten, dass
hier die Grenzen der tierischen Natur liegen,
in denen der formgebende Trieb, die formgebende
Kraft, der Körperbau und eine Spalte husten,
erscheint  sich auf die wunderbarste,
kapriziöseste Weise bewegen, ohne auch nur im
geringsten den Kreis zu durchbrechen oder zu
überspringen, der gestaltende Trieb ist
hier als Herrscher eines begrenzten und
doch gut versorgten Reiches die Rubrik
seines Budgets gesetzt, in der seine Ausgaben zu finden sind
verteilt werden, sind ihr vorgeschrieben und
doch ist das, was sie jedem zu X geben will,
frei, wenn sie
einem mehr lassen will, darf sie das aber nicht,
ohne es einem anderen zu nehmen, also
kann sich die Natur nie verschulden
geschweige denn gehen  bankrott Ich denke, das ist ein sehr
das ist eine Schlüsselpassage für uns Nachdenken
über den Trieb in Goethe gut, da die
ökonomische Analogie sowohl die
Freiheit als auch den Zwang, der den Vieren auferlegt wird,
auf den Antrieb beibehält  Einerseits ist der Gestaltungstrieb
völlig frei in der Verteilung der
Ressourcen nach Belieben, wodurch
neue Formen und Verteilungen ohne
vorgegebenes Ziel entstehen, andererseits
ist er an den Strukturplan gebunden,
dh er verteilt die
verfügbaren Ressourcen nach dem, was
Goethe die Idee eines a nennt  Haushalt
wie Geben und Nehmen, indem einige
Teile der Organisation in ihrer Komplexität erhöht werden, während
andere im Grad verringert werden, wodurch sie
für die Fortpflanzung des Organismus effizienter werden
Systeme werden weniger komplex und andere
komplexer entsprechend dieser
Beziehungen ergibt sich eine dynamische
Beziehung zwischen Innen und Außen und
hier noch ein Zitat aus der Handreichung
fragt man nach den Ursachen,
die eine solche Mannigfaltigkeit von Bestimmungen
ans Licht bringen, dann antworten wir vor allem dem
Tier wird durch äußere Bedingungen
für äußere c gebildet  Bedingungen also seine innere
Vollkommenheit und seine äußeren Zwecke
verfehlen Für Goethe scheint der Organismus
nach einem äußeren Zweck konstruiert zu sein,
denn seine innere Vollkommenheit wird
durch und für äußere Bedingungen besiegelt,
wenn die Funktion der Teile
als Ergebnis eines formgebenden
Triebes untersucht wird  man entdeckt, dass die
anordnung der teile
aus der dynamischen
beziehung zwischen art und umwelt erklärt werden kann. an
land sind die äußeren, zur bewegung genutzten organe
proportional zum körper angeordnet,
bei der schlange zum beispiel hat der körper eine
extreme länge und aus diesem grund  es
hat keine zusätzlichen Organe auf der Außenseite
, sobald wir diese zusätzlichen
Organe in einer anderen Formation finden, ein anderes
Gebäude sagen wir bei der Eidechse Goethe sagt,
der Körper wird viel kürzer beim
Frosch das Baumbein die langen Beine bedeuten, dass
die Form noch weiter zusammengezogen wird und
Die ungeformte Kröte ist
nach diesem
Ausgleichsgesetz in den Bedingungen des
Ozeans der Körper der Gestalt  Fisch nimmt
aufgrund
der Elementegesetze Goethes
gemäß den Gesetzen der organischen
Art einen maximalen Anteil an seiner Gestalt ein, jedoch wird die Schwellung des Körpers
durch die Kontraktion der
äußeren Organe kompensiert, die sich in
der Luft entwickelnde Art hat a  Trockeneres Inneres erklärt er damit,
dass im Vogel eine schlanke Form entsteht,
damit die formende Kraft
genügend Ressourcen hat, um die
Skelettstruktur und die Federn zu formen, die
es dem Vogel ermöglichen zu fliegen, so dass der
Adler sowohl durch als auch durch die Luft geformt wird
Goethe sagt durch die Höhe  Berge
und durch die hohen Berge, was bedeutet, dass
die Form der Teile und ihr
Verhältnis zueinander
von den Lebewesen bestimmt werden, von den Bedürfnissen des
Lebewesens bestimmt werden, was das Lebewesen
zum Überleben braucht, dies und die
Ente zum Beispiel zeigen die Neigung
dazu  das Wasser durch die Form bei Betrachtung
innerhalb der Natur verstanden als dieses
biodynamische System des Austausches die
Auswirkungen des Klimas die Höhe des
Berges  Wenn die Hitze der Kälte zusammen
mit den Wirkungen des Wassers und der
gewöhnlichen Luft für
die Bildung von Tieren äußerst mächtig werden, schlägt Goethe States
Gotas erster Entwurf eine radikale Änderung der
vergleichenden Anatomie vor, anstatt zu
fragen, warum bestimmte Merkmale
in einer von ihm geleiteten Art vorhanden sind  uns zu fragen, wie
der prägende Trieb formende Trieb für
bloße Triebe Platz für diese Merkmale
in seinem Budget findet, um herauszufinden, wie bestimmtes
Merkmal dazu kommt, dort zu sein, wo der Naturforscher
nach der Anpassung in anderen
Merkmalen sucht, die den prägenden Trieb möglicherweise gefördert haben
, formenden Trieb zu machen
bestimmte Kompensationen und es ist diese
Beziehung zwischen verschiedenen Teilen,
die betont werden, die die
spezifischen Bedürfnisse eines Organismus
in Bezug auf die Umwelt
bestimmen  Der Organismus
ist durch seinen Typ eingeschränkt, er ist nicht
geschlossen, sondern die Teile  sind
als Reaktion auf äußere Bedingungen proportioniert
, um die Anforderungen des
Strukturplans auszugleichen, so dass Goethe in den Jahren
nach dem ersten Entwurf
weiter an der MA-
Fallmethodik für ein neues System der
vergleichenden Anatomie auf der Grundlage der Morphologie arbeitete,
aber keine wesentlichen Arbeiten
folgten  An mehreren Stellen während des
nächsten Jahrzehnts drückte er seine Absicht aus
, seine Schriften in einem Band zu sammeln. Die
einzigen Texte zur Morphologie, die
vor dieser Veröffentlichung veröffentlicht wurden, waren
Metamorphosen von Pflanzen, aber diese
Sammlung entstand
erst 1817 in einem Preffer Tory-
Aufsatz, der für den geschrieben wurde  Sammlung Goethe
stellt die Morphologie als eine experimentelle
Wissenschaft dar, die mit der Beobachtung beginnt und
dann über jede Beobachtung hinaus
nach dem Prinzip hinter der Entwicklung
in tatsächlichen Lebewesen sucht. Der Schlüssel zur
vergleichenden Anatomie ist daher die Balance
zwischen der Notwendigkeit eines strukturellen Plans
mit Plastizität wie dem Plan  kann
sich im Laufe ändern o  In der
Reihenfolge und hier in diesem Text scheint
jeder ontologische Essentialismus in
Goethes Denken, wenn er überhaupt vorhanden war
, verschwunden zu sein, die Plastizität
des Strukturplans ist das, was die
organische von der anorganischen Natur trennt, während die
physische beides, während die physische Materie
ihren Ausdruck behält  Unveränderlich
bewirkt die durch den Gestaltungstrieb bewirkte wechselnde Beziehung der Teile
, dass das
organische Leben unaufhörlich seine
Gestalt verändert und dass auch seinen Bedürfnissen in jeder
Veränderung etwas entsteht, was
vorher noch nicht existierte, jedoch
organische Entwicklung, wenn es
dennoch einem unveränderlichen Gesetz unterworfen ist  Daher möchte ich
zum Schluss auf einen der in der
Zeitschrift „Morphology“ veröffentlichten Aufsätze mit dem
Titel „Building Schema
Formative Drive“ eingehen, und ich denke, hier können
wir die Bedeutung der Art und Weise
, wie Goethe seine vergleichende
Anatomie verstand,
anhand der Art und Weise erkennen, wie er sie in dem darstellt, was
er sieht  die Entwicklung der
Biowissenschaften und es ist ziemlich aufschlussreich, denke ich
, i  In diesem verkürzten Aufsatz wird die
Morphologie als Vollendung
einer Progression dargestellt, die mit Halle beginnt und
sich durch beide fortsetzt und in Blumenbach kulminiert,
so beginnt Goethe diesen Aufsatz,
indem er Halle als den Beginn
einer fortschreitenden Bewegung weg von der
Verwendung äußerer
Zweckzwecke identifiziert  für organische Form durch Erweiterung
des Yoga die Newtonsche Analogie zur
körperlichen Bewegung physiologische Bewegung
identifizierte Halla seine beiden Lebenskräfte
Sensibilität und Reizbarkeit, die
als Platzhalter für die Eigenschaften von
Muskelfasern standen, während die Lebenskräfte
es ermöglichten, auf innere
Eigenschaften organischer Fasern zu verweisen Halle  verneinte, dass sie
für morphologische Veränderungen verantwortlich sein könnten,
vielmehr bewirkt die Stimulation von Muskelfasern,
dass sich ein vorab etablierter Keim entfaltet
und wächst, den wir in Halehs Bericht
über die Bildung des Hühnerembryos sehen,
im Gegensatz dazu vertrat er eine
epigenetische Sichtweise, in der sich das Organische
wieder und wieder entwickelt  organische Art von Materie, die
mit einem Ess ausgestattet ist  ential force the visits and
Cialis erhält Lebewesen in
Goethes Begriffen sowohl vis essencial als auch
zu einer Kraft, die sich an
alles, was produziert wird, anpasst und somit
unabhängig von den Unterschieden zwischen Halehs evolutionistischer Darstellung auf die Ebene eines Produzenten erhoben wird
generation and vos epigenetic account
go-to erkennt an, dass beide in gewisser Weise
an Newtons materiellem
Konzept einer Kraft hängen bleiben, so abstrakt diese
Bindung auch ist
aus dieser substanz entstehen soll,
bleibt im dunkeln und in solium löslich
blumenbach hat Goethe weiter die
letzte verfeinerung dieser idee erreicht, denn er
vermenschlichte die phrasierung des rätsels Gerda stellt fest und nannte die sachliche diskussion anissas format
arvest einen antrieb eine handlungswelle,
die vermeintlich ist  was
die Bildung
Blumberg dadurch r verursachen sollte  Die Notwendigkeit,
einen äußeren Zweck anzunehmen, ist für seinen
Begriff des Triebes zwar keine
vorgegebene Fähigkeit, sondern ein
Gestaltungsprinzip, doch hält Blumenbach an
Halehs Newtonscher Rahmung fest,
um den Gestaltungstrieb darzustellen, er ist ein
Platzhalter für die unbekannte Ursache des
Gestaltungsprozesses, der  Irgendwie
materiell und zielführend ist Goethes
Behauptung meiner Meinung nach, dass Hulloh Wolf und Blumenbach durch die Untersuchung der
physiologischen Fähigkeiten durch eine
Analogie mit Newtonschen Kräften und dann
durch die gemeinsame Subsumierung der Fähigkeiten unter den
formativen Antrieb
begannen,
eine Wissenschaft der morphologischen Veränderung von
den Zwängen zu befreien  externe Teleologie,
und hier sieht er sich als
Höhepunkt dieser Tradition. Halla
erkannte, dass die Betrachtung eines
Lebewesens voraussetzt, dass man eine
Handlung voraussetzt
personifiziert wird, dann werden
wir zu dem Konzept geführt, in Zustände von
a zu gehen  Gott ein Schöpfer und Erhalter, den wir
gezwungen sind, Ehre und Lob anzubeten,
wenn es jedoch anthropomorphisiert
und als bestehend mit dem
zugrunde liegenden Material angesehen wird, ergibt sich ein neuer Rahmen für die
Untersuchung organischer Form, die
Entwicklung von Howletts einer blühenden
Rinde, so
dass Goethe jede Theorie der
Anpassung zitiert  und Anpassung wird
etwas voraussetzen müssen, das sich anpasst, und
etwas, woran es sich
anpasst  Anpassung der Epigenese,
so dass wir hier in dieser Kantinenweise eine
Art vertraute Erfüllung unseres
Verständnisses von Generation sehen, die
Teile aus Epigenese und Präformation zusammenbringt.
Diese Entwicklung wird
mit dem Konzept der Metamorphose abgeschlossen, das Goethe
behauptet, das die einzige Möglichkeit bietet, das
Zitat aufrechtzuerhalten  Einheit und Freiheit
seiner prägenden Drive in q  Die Uote-
Metamorphose befasst sich nicht mit festen
Formen, sondern mit fortschreitender Formation,
bei der Entwicklungsgesetzmäßigkeiten in
jedem einzelnen Organismus seinen
Typ ausdrücken und die Regelmäßigkeiten über einen Artentyp hinweg aufdecken.
Der vergleichende Anatom
kann daher zwischen verschiedenen
Analyseebenen arbeiten und zuerst das gemeinsame
Prinzip einer Art feststellen  Indem sie das
gemeinsame Prinzip einer Gattung und dann
einer Klasse bis hinauf zum
Tierreich und sogar zur Natur selbst bemerkt,
kann sie von jeder Ebene aus die
Verteilungstätigkeit des formenden
Triebs beobachten, der durch das Gesetz der
Kompensation gebunden ist völlig frei zu
verteilen  die begrenzte menge an
ressourcen, wo es in
gewissem sinne gotas verteidigung des bildungstriebs ist
, eröffnet dieses forschungsprogramm,
das so mächtig ist
, dass ich abschließend vorgeschlagen habe, dass Goethes ökonomische
analogie einen neuen rahmen für die
untersuchung der natur eröffnet  Ein groß
angelegtes Austauschsystem, das ich vorschlage,
gibt uns Anlass, über Aufklärung nachzudenken
sider gotas rezeption in der jüngeren geschichte der
biologie ein punkt, der von
mehreren kommentatoren in seinem ersten
skizzensatz vertreten wurde, verwebt die eigenwillige typologie
seiner
italienreise mit den wichtigsten
entwicklungen in der vergleichenden anatomie
seiner zeit und zeigt, wie ein strukturplan
in a erforderlich ist  System endloser
Wandlungsfähigkeit gehen zu der Erkenntnis, dass Halehs
Erweiterung der Newtonschen Kräfte auf
physiologische Eigenschaften die
Physiologie von der äußeren Zweckmäßigkeit entfernte,
und er sah, dass Blums formgebender
Antrieb einen neuen Blickwinkel auf den
formgebenden Prozess bot, in dem der
strukturelle Plan und die organische Materie
noch zusammen betrachtet wurden  Seiner Ansicht nach beschränkte die
Newtonsche Analogie die Analyse auf
organische Funktionen, wodurch der
wahrnehmbare und unaufhörliche Fluss der
organischen Form von der wissenschaftlichen Aufmerksamkeit
und Untersuchung ausgeschlossen wurde.
Daher schlug er das Innokin der Ökonomie
der Natur als alternative Analogie vor, mit
der nach einem Prinzip gesucht werden könnte,
das die Verteilung von regelt  ressourcen
, aus denen die vielfalt der lebenden
form hervorgeht dieses prinzip ist der gestalterische
trieb, der den schöpferischen
wandel der entwicklungswege lenkt Goethes
vorschlag ist natürlich vorläufig er
erklärt nicht, wie sich die a sanften
eigenschaften der gestalterischen kraft
von unserer eigenen schöpferischen tätigkeit unterschieden
Selbst in seinen späteren Arbeiten zur Morphologie ist
es nicht eindeutig, ob das zugrunde liegende
Muster von unserem Verstand auferlegt wird oder als
Vorlage, gefolgt von einer unabhängig
kreativen Natur, aber er ist für
vergleichende Anatomie programmiert, ist nicht unvereinbar
mit der Evolutionstheorie, die
sich nach ihm entwickeln würde, während er  war
unwissend über die Mechanik der Zeugung,
vielleicht sogar desinteressiert daran seine
Beobachtungsmethode erfordert keine
solche Analyse sein Ziel ist es vielmehr,
eine höhere Sicht auf die Natur als das System des
dynamischen Austauschs zu eröffnen, das nach
einem Gesetz organisiert ist, das nicht auf Mechanik reduziert werden kann
er sah, dass dies genau das ist,
was Darwin an The Origin of
S fasziniert  pecies
Darwins einziges Zitat von Goethe in diesem
Text bezieht sich auf sein Kompensationsgesetz,
das besagt, dass das Zitieren von Darwin
, um auf der einen Seite die Natur
zu verbrauchen, gezwungen ist, auf der anderen Seite zu sparen,
und
dieses Zitat in seiner
Untersuchung der Variationsgesetze auftritt, wo  Er
schlägt vor, dass der äußere Druck,
der auf eine Pflanze ausgeübt wird, bestimmte
Eigenschaften auf Kosten anderer auswählt.
Darwin fand eindeutig in der großen ökonomischen
Nettoanalogie einen Weg, die
Phänomenologie der Veränderung im Kontext zu untersuchen, in dem
äußerer Druck den
Ausdruck der inneren Form bestimmt. Mein Vorschlag
ist, dass wir  sollte - danke